Former President Donald Trump's
lawyers are now at the courthouse,
set to meet with District
Attorney Fani Willis
and negotiate
his surrender on RICO charges
tied to his effort
to overturn the 2020 election.
A short time ago, John
Eastman, a former
Trump lawyer
and a primary architect
of that 2020 election
subversion scheme,
agreed to a $100,000 bond.
And pro-Trump
poll watcher
Scott Hall agreed to a $10,000 bond.
Let's get you straight to the courthouse
now with CNN's Caitlin
Paul and Caitlin Eastman
obviously one of the biggest names
of the 19 defendants,
not including Donald Trump.
What's the latest
that you're learning about
what's happening
at the courthouse behind you.
Well, what we're learning
now at the courthouse from our own
Zach Cohen and Kaitlan Collins
is that Donald Trump's
lawyers are here
indeed doing the negotiations
for his own bond terms.
Donald Trump
being one of the 19 defendants
in this criminal case.
There are several different
defense lawyers
that are negotiating bond terms
just like John Eastman.
You just mentioned
has that $100,000 bond set.
Another defendant in this case
who was trying to
who is accused of trying
to access
the tabulating machines
in Coffee County, Georgia,
he has a $10,000 bond.
And so the big question of the afternoon
and throughout
the rest of this week
is going to be exactly how is Donald
Trump treated here
compared to the other defendants
in this case?
And then defendants
writ large in the state of Georgia
in Fulton County,
who are being accused of
white collar crime
or racketeering charges.
Does he have some sort of bail term
that is set and very similar
to these other defendants?
Is he treated
the same as other defendants?
We won't know that
until we see
what the agreement is
that his lawyers reached
with the prosecutor's office here.
And the judge signs off on it.
But once we get that document,
that is what we're going to
be looking for.
And then once that document
is in the system,
along with the documents,
for these other 18 defendants
alongside Trump,
they then all have to turn themselves in.
They all have to be arraigned.
They have to visit the jail,
and they will have to enter
their pleadings of not guilty.
And so that arrest process,
that arraignment process,
that's what's
teed up for the rest of this week,
perhaps arraignments
going into next week.
We're going to be watching
all of that play out
as Donald
Trump and others
working around him, including people
who are closely affiliated
with his campaign, people
who were lawyers for him as they run
a face with the criminal justice system
as criminal defendants
being accused of taking actions
that were illegal in the state of Georgia
after the 2020 election
to help the former
president maintain power,
even though he lost this state
and others across the nation.
Caitlin let's
zero in on the John Eastman agreement
take us through the details of that
Yeah there's a couple
different pieces of this
that are quite important.
One is that this
Eastman agreement
is the first
that we have of these 19 defendants
and one of the terms here
is that
John Eastman cannot communicate
with other defendants in this case.
He also can't communicate
with other witnesses
in this case about the facts of the case.
And so that means he's
not going to personally be able
to coordinate with other lawyers.
He might know
and have quite a long history
with who he was working with alongside
with Trump after the election.
He's not going to be able
to talk to Trump himself about this case.
They're going to have to talk through
their lawyers
or somehow through mediation.
And in some in some informal sense,
if they do want to
coordinate their legal defenses
in some way.
But that's a pretty strict term.
And if you do violate it,
you could be
in violation of your jail terms
or your bond terms,
meaning
you might have to go back to jail.
The other thing about this
is that $100,000 bond.
That doesn't mean
that you write a check for $100,000,
although I guess you can.
It means that you're essentially assuring
that you're going to keep showing up
and that you would owe that money
if you don't show up
for future proceedings,
if you were to abscond,
if you don't show up for trial,
something like that.
But it still is something that puts you
in the court system
as a criminal defendant
and makes
sure it's the guarantee to the court
that you as a defendant
will see this through
and they will be able to try a case
against you
as a defendant in the state of Georgia,
the first day
of a big week ahead in Fulton County.
Caitlin Pullen,
thanks so much for the reporting, Jeff.
We're joined now by Law Affairs
Fulton County
correspondent and about has been covering
this case very closely
since the beginning.
And good to have you on
with Trump's lawyers there.
Now, based on the way
other cases have been negotiated.
Is it likely that an agreement would come
today for his surrender
arrangement
or might this drag on for a little bit
I think it really
depends on kind of what's on the table.
I think it's likely that we see some
some agreement
on these standard conditions
that were entered on the consent bonds in
John Eastman's case,
and then Scott Hall as well.
That includes things
like not intimidating witnesses,
not con contacting co-defendants
except through counsel.
Those are things that are pretty
standard conditions
that I think will be easily
resolved and agreed to.
The big questions will be
whether they come to an agreement
about the bond amount
and then also
whether they come to an agreement
about the
the terms of surrender
that is due to happen by Friday.
While that is usually in
the realm of decision
making, with the sheriff's office
as to how to handle it.
So that's things
like whether or not
the defendant has a mug shot,
mug shot taken,
those things
usually are decided
by the sheriff's office.
But the sheriff has said
that unless he hears otherwise,
you know,
he will treat Trump and other defendants
the way that they usually
would be treated
like every other defendant.
But I think that means
that the district attorney does
have some decision making here
about how to approach it.
So we will see whether or not, you know,
Trump will be booked and weighed and
and has have his mug shot
taken like every other defendant.
The previous indictments Trump has faced,
he has not had to post bond.
Is it more likely, based on how we know
Fulton County runs and by the way,
first time
Fulton County has seen an indicted
president walk through those doors?
But but based on the way
they typically handle things like that,
is it more likely than not that
he would have to post bond
here, whereas he has
not in previous cases? I
certainly think that it will be likely
that he will post bond.
That is
very common in Fulton County.
I think that that will occur here,
especially now
that we've seen John
Eastman has a bond of $100,000
As Caitlin mentioned,
however, that is not the actual amount
that you have to pay.
You usually pay about 10%.
And the rest of it is
is more like an assurance
that you will pay it.
So I don't I think that what we will see
is that Trump will have a bond
that is higher than Eastman's.
It seems to be the case
that what we're seeing here
is a higher amount
based on the
involvement
or alleged involvement in the conspiracy.
So I would think that Trump,
out of all of the defendants, might have
the highest bond amount set
regardless of whether he has
to the former
president, take a mug shot,
give his fingerprints.
Those scenes
we've seen so often
for for others
going through a process like that,
he will still have to walk
through the doors of the Fulton
County Jail, walk through rooms
that other lower level
offenders must walk through every day
there.
Can you describe what that looks like?
What he will
certainly have to face there,
as opposed to questions
that are still open at this point?
Right.
So the facility
where Trump is likely to be booked,
although nothing is set in
stone, is
is what's known in Atlanta
as the Rice Street facility.
It is an infamous facility
in the Atlanta area.
It has been subject of numerous lawsuits
for inhumane treatment
and conditions of individuals
who are incarcerated there.
Most recently, it was the
subject of national headlines
when it was alleged
that an incarcerated person died
there as the result of a
bedbug infestation.
So it is a place that certainly no one
wants to end up.
And Trump
will have to walk through that facility
and like any other defendant,
spend some time there.
How long?
It's unclear,
but he's he certainly will be
treated like other defendants
in that respect.
It's a remarkable scene to imagine
And Bauer, thanks so much.
Appreciate it.